Willie Garson throws major shade at Sex
in the City co-star Kim Cattrall oh the
fans seem to want it
let's hope fans aren't the only one
speaking out after cast members
confirmed a planned third movie set to
start production this fall was canceled
it's all your fault oh darling Willie
who plays Stanford the best friend of
Carrie Bradshaw took to social media on
Wednesday with a cryptic tweet seemingly
aimed at Kim he wrote quote dear fans
because I'm toxic I'm going to negotiate
a contract for six months not come to
terms then say I never wanted to do it
anyway
it's bizarre because the mania has gone
on for so long now the actors comments
come after reports surfaced claiming Kim
was responsible for the film getting
shelved
but Kim has denied she caused the
trouble saying she never even began
contract negotiations and back in
January she didn't seem on board to
reprise her role as Samantha telling et
quote I hate to be a spoil sport but
what would the next story be the reality
of what a third movie would be there's
nothing concrete
[Music]